thank you
[Music]
so you guys know how when Federal
officials take office they swear on like
a Bible or like maybe a Quran keep some
honest it keeps them honest sort of the
Torah or whatever the religious the
belief is Right black Court um pamphlet
yeah
if I go to yeah if I go to court they're
like all right you could you probably
tell the truth and I'm like man only on
a Playboy whose titties are my hand
gonna be on a
1995 issue of Pamela Anderson's first
debut and then Nicole Smith that's a
good pick I would put it on the the
sports Almanac from Back to the Future
too that's sick remember when you go
back in time you can't can't bet on the
almanac
can't lose what would you do it on
um what this guy did so he he is a
congressman he's taken the the oath on a
million dollar Superman comic oh
actually Comics number one holy [ __ ]
well this one's not actually Comics
number one oh this is the first Superman
single issue after it was actually yeah
Superman exactly like his Superman
number one not Action Comics number one
first appearance of Superman which is
worth significantly more money wow like
this is worth one million dollars I
think it's I think it's worth five
million yeah that's a lot too dude I
think it's worth five million dollars
but action conference number one is
worth like [ __ ] it's like the the
most popular oh wow right you like swear
on that
I think well he he uh he is he got this
one on apple pie so I could put my hand
inside and then go oh that's a good idea
it better be warm though oh my God see
that's even better than mine I want to
swear on a marionette so I can control
that to swear on a Mini Bible
a
condom
that's cool yeah because I'm not really
swearing it's true so he got the comic
from the Library of Congress yeah you're
smarter than this part you know that I
don't know what you're saying and nobody
cares like this but he got it from the
library Congress
and um he got the comic book from
Library of Congress yeah Library
Congress has like a [ __ ] ton of books
they like preserved I don't know they
got all that cool [ __ ] but you can't
normally just like look at it right it's
like not that's not that kind of like I
don't know I don't know how it works
it's not that kind of like you gotta do
the white glove stuff like you know how
when you gotta do the historical at
artifact [ __ ] you gotta be like I'm a
special person that deserves to see this
and you schedule some [ __ ] and they take
you to a ball Wish Foundation and then
they they bring like a book out and then
they like they like they [ __ ] turn
the pages and then you have to wear
gloves and [ __ ] you seen that yeah I've
seen it I've seen two you see it with
like tongues you turn the pages like
tongue yeah you gotta use Tom you know
how like like um you get Chopsticks and
[ __ ] you get a whole lobster the lobster
does it a bunch of presidents swore in
on the Bible that Abe Lincoln used so
they do the same [ __ ] right they take it
from the Library of Congress and then
they put their hand on it that's pretty
dope yeah because you don't technically
have to swear on anything right it's
just they choose to do that I have no
actual idea so like I don't think I'll
keep the respect uh
you don't have to swear on anything at
all really you just have to you just
have to swear Bible is a default if you
don't click anything else
you don't select the Superman you can
choose other things to swear on but what
the atheists use nothing you don't have
to do it probably the apple pie thing
why did the picture of the Spaghetti
Monster
truck yeah they're like we didn't have a
pie with atheists today of course
like we need another apple pie it's the
Marine calendars
that's not ASMR yeah yeah you gotta Mash
your hand in it anyone else
so I was with the Buddy recently and I
was pretty proud because I started this
like little tiny little teeny tiny
little comic book collection after Luna
died after Luna died I was like I need
to collect something that maybe will
preserve its value that'd be kind of
crazy and then I was like what could
that be and I was like oh well I always
like comic books right so I started this
little comic book collection right what
was the first one you got chicken um
okay my favorite one so far is I got
it's such a small Flex
Batman number one oh for real I don't
know that's like [ __ ] what million
dollars you'd be saying that every day
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah
I wouldn't be wearing it on a chance
laminated no I got um I got this
Spider-Man once like the first
appearance of uh uh Spider-Man 2099. oh
that's pretty tired
I got the Spider-Man's wedding comic
here I don't want to go dig it's right
here so I was telling my butt about this
right because he is going through a
medical thing right now
um and I was at his place and he like
can't really go anywhere or whatever for
a while and then I was like yeah dude so
come back let's get a bunch of cool
Spider-Mans and [ __ ] he's like oh you
got a bunch of cool Spider-Mans that's
cool he's like
let's go upstairs with me all right so I
go upstairs and he takes me into his
bedroom
and he takes his dick out yeah
so he opens his closet and the closet is
just [ __ ] comic book boxes oh [ __ ]
and it's all Spider-Man all of it whoa
and he pulls out Amazing Fantasy number
15 which is Spider-Man number one first
is that the one with the Fantastic Four
like flying around yeah the first spider
how much is that worth [ __ ] a lot
like but it's kind of his his version
17.50
right it's kind of like his wife it's a
beast is it graded is it gonna see it on
eBay
can you see it on eBay like it's for
sale on eBay yeah I'll show you you want
to see it they're like 50 Grand though
beat like that
um it can be really not like that when
it's when it's beat when it's beat it's
like the mark the
what's it called it's so wide what it
could be worth It's like because it's
like every bunch of person with like
there's this place called cgc right and
that's like the comic grading like are
they appraising stuff yeah now there's a
lot of controversy with it if you're
real [ __ ] into this [ __ ] is cgc a
physical place or you gotta like they do
it online you gotta send it in you have
to send it in you have to like board it
and send it in like in a certain way
depending on how much you pay you get it
back but this is Amazing Fantasy and I
actually held this in my [ __ ] head oh
that's not the one I was thinking damn
oh uh no this is oh yeah this one
doesn't have the Fantastic Four does it
is that food dangling by his weiner but
he had that one too he had that one too
12 cents it came out yeah dude so this
thing yeah it came out I'm gonna grab my
Spiderman go get it all right you guys
keep talking I want to show you guys
history okay Joe okay we're gonna shut
the video yeah
can do your thing
you can't do what you do best baby kids
like your time
[Music]
Joe's gonna come back we're in a deep
story Somebody's Crying it's like the
deepest moment in JK history so I can't
find it God damn it it's back by itself
by the way has anyone ever done this
before they like did something cool has
anyone ever done this as a kid when
you're hacking yeah yeah I do that and
then I go wait this doesn't really
stretch me out like why did I do this I
do this to pop my Knuckles sometimes it
hurts my time right before I'm beating
it up you look like an idiot it's like a
virgin okay so yeah so he pulls out you
know and no matter what I said that I
had he pulled it out and it's better
condition he's just pants me the whole
time it is incredible but I'm like at
least I'm not dealing with your medical
condition
what do you say he had nothing to say
after that right nothing to say how do
you think about this white beat so like
how do you go about acquiring the stuff
for your collection like where do you
just like I just went through eBay
because it was like yeah easy mode but
like um oh I actually went to a couple
local spots the local comic shops in
Vegas too if you do you remember Frank
and Sons yeah what's that I only got
frankincense like so it's like a it's a
basically a giant looks like a giant
Costco of nothing but like collectible
boots it looks like that should only be
there a day but it's their own kid you
would just nut in there for like three
hours you'd be like I can't wait to go
to Frankensteins you carpool with your
buddies and stuff like that you're just
lost right if you ever want to go my
friend can't find it someone give them
20 bucks
I don't want to spend too much time I
couldn't find it is it in Cali dude you
got like yeah it's like in the 66 yeah
it's like uh his buddy owns a Spider-Man
Booth he owns the Spiderman it's called
that Spider-Man booth and it's all
Spider-Man stuff at frankincense you
guys ever been in like flea markets and
like sometimes they have like these old
tables where they just have uh they just
sell old comic books do you think you'd
ever find some good [ __ ] there
absolutely yeah I'll tell you what
that's what Comic-Con was I went to a
vintage store to help a friend buy some
desks right and then uh because they
wanted like some like real mid-century
modern [ __ ] not like the mid-century
[ __ ] not mid-century modern and then
there's a section it was like it was
five bucks for every bundle of like
basketball cards like this much WoW like
five bucks I was like I'll just get a
couple and then I looked through it
there's a bunch of like original all
deadlift shrimps uh Shaquille O'Neal
like rookie cards
checked it all on eBay and it wasn't
working but um some of them were it
arranged some of them I was like oh [ __ ]
I did like one of them like Michael
Jordan card was like 1700. what and then
you have it and I checked this homie
Scottie Pippen and he was like what 12
cents yeah
well that's basically their entire
relationship I know wait are we gonna
gloss over the fact that you bought for
five dollars you got all that [ __ ] and
one one of them's worth 1700 yeah I
checked it when David was at my house I
was like oh I got basketball we're just
talking about basketball cards and we
checked it together it doesn't matter
because Bart spent 700 on [ __ ]
Postmates in a week
great stuff she's gonna have a heart
attack
this guy's [ __ ] budget is crazy
what is this fun bow way
but he's like oh Jeff I'm out he's
looking he's like oh I should have
ordered Japan is it too late no it's too
late
now too late he's still eating footage
she's busy
can did you order lunch yet you already
deleted the orders he said no he said we
can do it how many of you guys want to
jump out well we're gonna add it to the
menu what are you trying to get
every time
how many of you guys want one
get one it's a dessert one for each
table one free stuff
I don't know no one [ __ ] knows it's
like hollow hollow
I used to have like three different
jellies three or four three or four
three four
[Music]
laughs